depuis 3h ce matin les sapeurs pompiers
des yvelines sont à pied d'oeuvre la
tempête et léa nord a frappé le
département plus de 180 agents ont été
mobilisés pour sécuriser les zones à
risque on avait un arbre qui menaçait un
poste de détente de gaz donc il a fallu
le coupé et le faire tomber afin de
sécuriser les abords pour pas qu'ils
tombent sur des passants sur des
véhicules à rambouillet on est les 12 de
personnel de la garde fonds mobilisés on
a fait appel à quelques personnels de
repos afin de grossir les rangs au total
plus de 160 interventions surtout dans
le sud et l'ouest du département c'est
ici au centre opérationnel départemental
d'incendié et de secours que les quatre
opérateurs coordonne des événements
principalement ceux du dégagement en
arbre ou de branches d'arbres sur la
voie publique on a aussi des fils
électriques tombés sur la voie publique
et après on a des objets menaçant de
tomber en ville ça peut être des
éléments de cheminées des tuiles des
choses comme ça les sapeurs pompiers ont
aussi travaillé en partenariat avec
d'autres services par endroits la
tempête à abîmer les installations
électriques à magny les hameaux et nady
c'est la police municipale sont
intervenus rapidement vers 6h30
un arbre a chuté sur la voie publique en
entraînant avec lui un câble électrique
j'ai été moi déclenchée par par la
brigade de gendarmerie de magny les
hameaux
voilà vingtaine d'habitations peu près
touché par une coupure d'électricité qui
devrait normalement rétablie dans la
journée à la mi journée encore 480
foyers étaient privés d'électricité dans
les yvelines un retour complet à la
normale est prévu dans la soirée mais la
prudence reste de mise même si la
vigilance orange a été levée par météo
france dans le département